[Music]
super-quick Who am I I am Dan Goldin
I've been at triple lifts for five years
I joined when we were 12 people we're
about 200 now
and we ran at the company that's doing
real-time bidding and I'll get into
exactly what that is the reason I'm
talking years because I was pretty
instrumental I would say writing many of
the versions in the past that are
currently being fixed by others to
correct all the mistakes I've made and
we'll be covering in detail and my goal
with this presentation is really to talk
about really the narrative of the
different steps our pipeline took so
it's evolution because oftentimes you
will see kind of the end result and you
won't really understand or appreciate
like what were the motivations to get
there you won't really realize like well
what sort of missteps occur down the way
so I'm trying to be a bit more
transparent with the pursuit with the
hope that at least others kind of see
the trade-offs we have to think about
see technology's choices we made at
different points in time and obviously
at the end if anyone has any questions
anyone could ask so it's a pretty simple
agenda I'm gonna spend maybe about 5-10
minutes explaining like attic because it
really sets the context for the the rest
of the presentation because if you don't
understand the challenges like with an
attic of like what does the data look
like how much is the data the rest of
the presentation doesn't really make a
ton of sense so I'm going to spend some
time talking about that I'll talk about
the evolution of the various data
parameters we've had it's gonna be
covering like five distinct pieces keep
in mind it's I'm gonna make it seem very
black-and-white it was definitely not
the case there's definitely overlap from
one version to another version because
that's really what happens in your
billing Oh like big data systems and
then the the last bit is talk a few
lessons learnt there will be less and
sprinkle out throughout from that
particular version of our pipeline but
I'm gonna wrap it up by saying kind of
three I would say like Universal or like
holistic lessons that we picked up just
along the way that apply to every single
thing or at least some of the lessons we
learnt along the way so pretty simple
talking about like data in that if you
do a simple search on Google for a tech
big data you get millions of results
there's obviously something there
they generally tend to be synonymous you
can't really consider yourself out
saying a tech company if you're also not
working with big data
so the
questions like like why there's a very
simple example if you load up the New
York Times home page with this chrome
eccentric old ghost story it'll tell you
all the analytics and tracker code
that's running so just by loading up the
home page of the New York Times
you see 39 companies code being executed
on that page that have there are New
York Times they're really just vendors
that are collecting stats like who is
the user how long did they spend on the
page yada yada yada yada and it's like
well why at some level begs the question
of why are all these companies
collecting this data like what's so
special about it simple very quick
simple answer auctions real time bidding
auctions and I'll do a very quick
overview of exactly what that means done
here
so super simple if you're familiar with
a deck this won't be you consider us a
refresher if you're not familiar without
take prepare to have your mind blown
what happens is every time you land on
the webpage that's rubbing advertising
the browser sends an ad requests to an
exchange doesn't really matter what the
names are ignore them it basically sends
this adder goes to a server and it
contains information about you the user
like what state are you in
what time is it what browser are you
using an exchange it then sends it out
to a couple through these companies
called DSPs that have like basically
code the proprietary bidding algorithm
that'll say well oh it's Dan he's
looking at the New York Times using this
browser how about we serve up an ad for
a Toyota Camry and then they decide how
much is an impression to me worth they
submitted up stream back to back to the
exchange and the exchange runs the
second price auction to determine who is
the winner of this auction in order to
then serve an ad back to the browser to
have a rendered and the user hopefully
sees the ad clicks it engages whatever
the case may be so this is happening if
you really go to the website you see the
amount of ads they have one of these is
happening for every single ad so there's
a ton of data really being collected
throughout the process right both for
the ad requests being sent out as well
as the bidding behavior as well as all
the data people are collecting around
engagements so there's like just a huge
outside like pool of
being collected by like every company
across the industry and something that's
I would say even like super interesting
is all this literally does happen faster
in the blink of an eye like on average
about like 200 milliseconds from the
very beginning from the time of the
request is made to an exchange back to
in surrender so there's obviously a
strong need to do things like at scale
very quickly so that's a very quick
overview of the way real-time bidding
works and sets up the foundation in
particular talking about the data side
of the business it's useful to think
about what data is actually collected at
each step like in a pipeline or like is
being generated at each stuff in this
auction so like very simple in the case
of an ad request it's before any buyer
has seen what the information or it has
really done any evaluation so at this
point all you really know is really what
the user or the browser sends over so
you have IP address which people use to
their camera the geolocation you have
the user agent which is used to
determine like the browser the west's
device you have a few more information a
bit more information around like user
IDs if you've seen them before you may
be able to say oh they like have seen
these ads so there's generally
information about that particular ad
request the next step is the bid request
that gets sent to these DSPs and they're
generally similar but there is some
salties where different companies have
different protocols there's slight
information that's modified depending
who you're talking to
generally you want to collect this
information just because you want to
really dig in though identify some
issues so just one of those things that
just adds more more volume lastly once
you get the bid responses back what do
you know you collect information about
like the brand the price you collect
about the ad itself is it an ad for
going back to our example is an ad for a
Toyota is an ad for Samsung you're
really just getting information about
the brand how much they're willing to
pay and then once it's once the exchange
runs the soft in terms the winner like
it's not always going to be the highest
price because if the particular website
says hey I don't want any alcohol ads on
my website if a buyer wants to serve an
ad for a Budweiser is gonna get rejected
and it'll go to the next highest so
there's a variety of business rules that
this exchange
applies in order to then send response
back to
the browser and then lastly as a bonus
you also start collecting engagement
metrics which can only happen in the
browser like did the user click was it
in view if it's a video how much of the
video did they watch so all this
information is being collected really
for every single or nearly every single
event that the kind of the industry sees
so this is a bit of a stretch but it
helps me think of what how to think
about the problem if people aren't
familiar with the Drake Equation it was
it was this idea of how do we estimate
the number of alien civilizations that
could communicate with us and you look
at the equation it's really just a
factor of x and if others together like
what is the rate of kind of universe is
being created well how long are they
active for with the general idea like
the parallel to me is it's a ton of
different like factors that you then
multiply together to come up with like
some sort of number and it's really this
idea of than just blowing up sort of
your I would say cardinality and
dimension space so these numbers I'm
gonna share our specific to triple lift
and you can consider us being I would
say like a small to mid-size add to
company so companies like like Google
Facebook they're in advertising their
scales are like order magnitude probably
multiples or arm active bigger than what
we do but also we're not like the
smallest company so like take of it as a
example what roughly a 200 person at
that company sort of experiences so high
cardinality what does that mean if we go
back to the previous kind of slide when
we're discussing the data pieces being
collected you see that there's a browser
you see that there's OS you see that
there's region and see the buyer so all
these we have roughly 50 of these I
would say like unique dimensions for a
particular first thing you know add
request so and you can imagine if you're
doing data analysis that's a lot of data
that you have to like slice and analyze
and collect over you couple that with
this idea that there's a lot of volume
we're doing four billion ad requests
every day right so you take the 4
billion ad request with these 50
dimensions and some of the dimensions
themselves are a high cardinality right
there's 50 states if you're
International there's a lot more regions
if you're looking at browsers did I
think how specific you want to get you
have like 15 browsers if you're looking
at a number of campaigns a number of
brands they're like hundreds of
thousands of brands so each of these
combined with the fact that there's four
billion of these happening every
like like seriously adds up on top of
that you take a look at ad tech and
fundamentally it's an extremely low
value like each of these individual ad
requests is worth fractions of a penny
so and this right here isn't but we
don't always win in the auction so what
really happens is oftentimes you get an
ad request you submit a bid if you don't
win you're still paying for the
processing you're still paying for the
storage you're still paying for all
these things you've had to do to that
individual event and if you do win it's
really worth fractions of a penny so
their ultimate idea is how do you do
these things like like when you think
when we're talking about a data pipeline
it's how do we still make it successful
or accessible to our users while at the
same time being cost effective at the
same time being able to like just handle
the scale so I'll dig into like our
evolution of the thought process and
kind of how we've approached it in the
technologies we've used so this is some
numbers I'm gonna go read them but if
you're familiar we're like the various
bits of technology here like I think
some of the numbers will stand out
probably the most interesting one I
mentioned is the four billion ad request
a day but that really means we're doing
a hundred forty billion bid requests
because we get an ad request and then we
fan it out to a bunch of different
companies and that sort of multiplies to
the effect we're doing we're collecting
important parties we're collecting about
three hundred a thousand events a second
like some of the events we sample just
because the loads too high others we
collect every single one so I'm sure
it's gonna be recorded so you can review
the numbers after I don't want to read
every single number but just suppose you
frame the size of the problem here it's
pretty big so now talking about the
actual evolution of the pipeline and
I'll dive in and or before I dive in I
kind of want to explain how we think
about the data pipeline and this is the
framework we'll use to really look at
our evolution this is pretty similar to
like this ETL analogy but in the case of
like at least maybe in the attic version
I view it as this idea of there's some
events being generated and right now
there's sample technologies that are
considered to be within each group so
there's Kafka for storing the events
there's the processing which is you
realize we've we're getting four billion
of the events a day like we need to do
something in order to transform them so
the team ETL in order to make them and
then store them in order then make them
accessible for our users so and I'm
gonna each of the following version of
the pipeline we're gonna kind of
leverage this idea of yeah the event
collection the processing the storage
and then the access to think of how our
system evolves so v-0 it's purposely
zero because it doesn't really deserve a
real version and it's got information
highlights in quotes because I would say
these aren't really highlights but the
key idea here is when we started so this
think of it this as five years ago
and I'll give a timeline as well then
just to put things in perspective but
like this is a symbol of a pipeline as
you can get we didn't want to collect
every one of these events we've seen it
was too expensive what we do is in the
browser we just have like a little
function that says hey if math dot
random is less than 0.1 send an event
off so this is basically saying sample
events one out of ten we set them to a
little node application on the back end
that node application would do it's a
tradition in memory it would write these
aggregations to my sequel every few
minutes and then we'd have another job
that would run daily that would take
these samples kind of mini eggs and roll
them up to a daily level so that's
simple each of these four steps Maps
exactly to this idea like to this kind
of reading what we discussed and that's
that so and this is the framework I'll
kind of take I think through all this so
why did we do this it was extremely
simple it leveraged all the existing
technology we had it was not a lot of
work and it really gave us what we need
to do at that time
like at this point we're a team of a
dozen people like we're not gonna be
investing in all this like big data
infrastructure just because there's just
so much overhead both in the both and
like setting it up but both in the cost
of running it uh-huh so next like what
challenges do we run into it's pretty
obvious when we had any issues we were
investigating off of sample data so
imagine trying to do any analysis where
one out of you missed 94 than your
events
99% of events so that's kind of chances
we run into we had a ton of event loss
because it was if there was any hiccup
in my sequel like that insert thing that
insert failed and we weren't able to
collect that data and also the non
scalable like this entire
was relying like once equal customer no
application we tried spending it up more
up and fundamentally just didn't really
work for as we grew larger at the same
time like one key got pretty far with a
very simple system like I know there's a
lot of went right now especially if you
look at like just amount of tools out
there there's a huge amount but like the
realities you could get pretty far if
you're willing to make some compromises
and it's only when you realize you have
a problem do you have to think about or
taking it to the next level and there's
a little example of a error message we
would receive in 2015 when like an
insert failed right you get these email
to you and usually they come in batches
because that's all you'd have one
failure you'd probably have like maybe a
couple hundred within the span of a few
minutes so we get this giant email
someone have to copy this query paste it
into a Brett and paste it into my Segal
client running it and like that would
fix our data pipeline so this is a like
I would say how simple things were back
in the day so next version and this is
really this idea of moving away from
really the sample ID and starting to
collect every single date event and
really building I would say the start of
a modern data modern data infrastructure
so what we would do here one capturing
every single single every single event
we're starting to use Kafka which is
really I would say like the industry
standard for collecting like log level
data it's either Kafka or if you're on
the cloud like a double issues Kinesis
but generally I don't think anyone uses
like everybody static anything else cuz
copy just has the scale redone see the
distribution to like make things work we
also started using redshift with a few
hacks in between and I don't necessarily
want to not sure I have time to think
into each one but if you go to office
hours like I definitely share it but
generally we have the data going in
Kafka we use this application called say
core which is which was open source by
Pinterest and all it does is it reads
from Kafka in a variety of different
protocols
so either JSON or pro buff or like
thrift in our case we use protobuf takes
that data from Kafka converts it to
another set of output format so we use
Parque uploads it to us three and then
it takes that data that used to be in
Kafka elbows to s3 and then you could do
whatever you want with the furnace city
what we did in this version is we hack
the hell out of sake or so after it also
to us three it would also publish a
message to rabbit and then our
we had a separate process I hae the ad
request date has been uploaded or the
click date has been uploaded read it
from this s3 location loaded into
redshift and then we had a whole
separate process that would take the
data this log level data from redshift
and then use it to run act jobs in order
to generate Ag tables that were in
redshift once again so use here redshift
as both the store for our log level
events as well as the store for our AG
tables as well as the actual like
processing engine so in this case like
the redshift sort of became the bread
for what we did we still for whatever
reason we'll talk about it later but we
had to we built like a home-built
scheduler system I do not recommend it
you should definitely use something
that's already out there but yeah so
when we did introduce a few technologies
here and this is really the start of
decoupling to various steps of a data
file and really making something that is
much more modern much more in tune with
what people I would say normally think
of like a Big Data kind of transport big
data pipeline but at the same time you
also see the complexity here in the past
it was very linear right it was like
four boxes data from one goes to the
next go to the next here you're already
starting to see some branching you're
already starting to see systems being
decoupled and like that's in general I
like in general as you get larger and as
you build like a real life system you
start to decouple systems it makes it
easier to develop it makes it easier to
test it lets you I would say introduced
fault tolerance into your system like in
our case if any of the add jobs failed
or the log like the log loads failed we
because we still have the data on s3
because of sake or like we didn't really
have to worry about it but our pipeline
began then suddenly delayed by a few
hours or maybe a few minutes instead of
actually having to like actually lose
data like which is like the big no-no in
the industry yeah so like pretty simple
like why do we do this really it's we
needed to move towards like level events
we just couldn't really work with
sampling anymore we obviously wanted the
resistant or the resilient scalability
like what channels do we run into one a
big one was when we moved to redshift we
realized that every single piece orab
time we need to enact we have to do it
through sequel and sequel gets you
pretty far but we couldn't do anything
that was statistical in nature or we
found ourselves working over backwards
to do like queries that use like nested
queries to used window
to do things that would have been much
simpler to code but because we were on
redshift we really had to use sequel for
that there's a the next two are pretty
interesting like one is what ended up
happening is as the as our users of both
internal-external saying hey we need
this dimension exposed we need let's say
we need a table that has domain we near
the table has browser we need a table
that has region what ends up happening
is you end up having like these
aggregate tables per specific use case
so by the end of it we had maybe about
like two dozen three dozen tables
designed from different use cases that
customers wanted and well it was nice
from the standpoint of performance it
was got pretty annoying like like
fundamentally over it and we were
thinking for something is there one way
for us to just put everything in one
table that's actually cheap and
performance that could give us the
problem that could still give everyone
like the ability to like slice dice the
way they wanted to yeah job scales
really always a problem just an example
of something we ran into as an example
of like a job scheduling issue is once
we have too much data what we ended up
doing is we we started having like daily
jobs and no crap we have too much data
let's switch him to hourly what happens
if one hour fails oh we run that hour
but that hour suddenly is linked to the
day and there's this other act that's
based on this other eye and we have to
do all this I would say like like home
built so it was not a fun problem I
would probably say we spent more time
than we should have I'm just doing the
simple stuff of like a wiring jobs
together
yeah and lastly what we realize like why
we ended up overtime moving away from
his redshift just got prohibitively
expensive we initially stored it like
maybe two weeks worth of log level data
than a week then three days than two
days just because we couldn't store all
that while it's still being kind of
price-conscious
yeah and then another big lesson we
force a core way back when we never
touched his since so we really didn't
get to take advantage of any of the new
kind of solutions or new performance of
moments that came with right and because
we were like let's not void breaking
anything we kind of kept it the way it
is so I would suggest not doing not
forking open source code or if you for
contributing back to the main repository
so a continuation of like a newer
version this is where we ripped out
redshift
for the processing and replaced replaced
the processing part with spark which is
really a way to write distributed I
would say like a computational code it's
I don't know if everyone's familiar with
it but generally you're writing code
neither like Scala or Python they also
have like our code and it spins it up
through a cluster and it really works on
this idea of like resilient data frames
where if any one node goes down it will
replicate it to another node and do
really a series of Map Reduce operations
to kind of do the actual data processing
the nice thing is it took sequel so it's
actually very easy for us to port our
code from redshift to spark because
spark has the ability to write sequel
and then we also replaced not all of
them but some of our redshift a bulk of
our redshift acts with this product
called druid and drew it is this really
large scale analytics datastore it was
created by coming called Metamarkets
which has since been acquired by snap
but what it's designed for is very
similar to the way I think about is it's
not based on sequel at all it's really
designed around optimizing one single
table but the way it works is it does it
stores it in backs up on this three it
stores the memory through common format
but it's key advantages it's designed
for more of these interactive analytics
so it's not necessarily designed to give
you perfect results but it's designed to
give you like 99th percentile accurate
results with by but able to do a much
quicker so it's like do you want
accuracy then use redshift do you want
something that's just quick and easy to
like slice and dice use Druitt and we
actually ended up moving maybe a dozen
of our sort of brush attacks to this
prod called druid and we really had one
giant file so when I spoke about we had
like 50 dimensions we really just loaded
a file in here like a CSV file that at
50 columns four dimensions 30 columns
for metrics and let druid kind of handle
all the indexing all the optimization
and the UI's around that are actually
pretty cool there's a company called
imply that creates like a really nice
tool to like slice and dice data there's
gonna be called or an open or are called
superset that also lets you really
drag-and-drop dimensions immediately see
what it would look like if you've ever
used looker this is really like looker
that's like without having to hit the
wrong button it immediately updates like
as you play around with the tool so it's
incredibly powerful
yeah so like following the same throw
version before really what was the
problem
wretched real just became expensive it
just didn't come like f cost-effective
effective for us to use it anymore
and we want to move away from sequel
what did we really what channels did we
run into there is we've gotten to the
point here where migrating data from
like one system to another system is not
very straightforward I think anyone here
who's worked on like regular code like
what do you do oh you deploy new version
of your code everything's great oh it
sucks roll it back deploy another
version you can't really do that with
data if you have three years worth of
data and you're like well let's load
into another database like that's gonna
cause either a lot of time or a lot of
money I'll probably both so like that's
a big challenge we ran into moving data
from like one system to another we
really ended up taking a compromised
position by saying hey let's not load
every dimension we ever had let just
sort of zero out or null some of these
dimensions just to get older data in
there and have the top level metrics
make sense but not necessarily have any
of the low level like the ability to
like slice dice the other thing is we
were at this point the team's pretty
small we were like two or three
engineers and it's like now on top of on
top of like the Java system with a path
Kafka on top of like knowing the
redshift world time to learn druid time
to learn spark so like these are all
like new technologies that our team had
to learn and you you go pretty far kind
of reading documentation trying things
out but it's just something of concern
right but over time you end up
introducing more and more complexity to
your stack more time knowledge
standpoint but also from a maintenance
standpoint and yet lastly this is
something that uh I really like I found
from this step to do I would say like
the major lessons to me is one s3 is
extremely versatile being able to like
jump does just dump data onto s3 and
then have whatever system you want
process whether it's spark whether it's
loading it from like s3 into redshift
like it's just this very nice cheap data
store that gives you this option ality
to build whatever tool on top you want
the speaker before talk about snowflake
like you can load data from s3 into
snowflakes so it's now you have a
completely new sort of database based on
that same log level data
so I recommend like just using a 3-story
as much data as you can it's generally
much
cheaper than anything else it's cheaper
to even like store multiple versions of
the same data in different like formats
just improve improve your query time
computation time and then lastly like
I'm not trying to be like hyperbolic
here like sequel really is wonderful it
exists it's like the 60 70s
and like we still use it and like you
just copied a it like we'd really
literally to migrate from redshift to
jobs to like spark we just copy and
paste of the queries change the table
names and in that way it works perfectly
fine like it's just incredibly powerful
being able to do that so almost almost
event this is like the last one and the
idea here is we introduced the lambda
architecture into our system if people
aren't familiar with a land architecture
it's this idea of collect have a real
time system and a badge system that run
side by side and write to the same
designer datastore so the idea being you
could have a real time system that's
surrounding minutes behind seconds
behind it doesn't do the perfect job in
terms of accuracy but it gets you
directionally correct data much quicker
and then three hours later four hours
later when the Batchelor Sun catches up
you sort of overwrite that data with the
more actor data that was generated by
the batch system and Druid which is uh
which we've been using for this supports
both so drew it lets you let us load
both data from these like park' like csv
large batch files but it also let us
read directly from Kafka so if you can
see here we kept the batch system as we
had from before we introduced this other
class we introduced both DB which let us
read data from Kafka volt would do these
joins in memory it would publish them to
another Kafka topic and then Druid would
reach from that Kafka topic put into the
same data store and then and then none
of our API tools or like BI tools really
had to change like which is actually
pretty incredible being able to say hey
suddenly we introduced technology we
didn't really have to change like the
interfaces at all we just have to make
figuration changing through it and now
we have data that's like delayed when
maybe like a minute like even less in
some cases so he did just being able to
like do that's pretty powerful yeah so
we introduced volt DB here which is this
is my sort of like blurb unlike how I
think about it I'm sure it's much more
complicated than that
but it's able
to run extremely high performance loads
it's meant to be like a transactional
like like database so things like my
sequel but it's supposed to be much more
performant because you're one defining
all the logic that's gonna run on ahead
of time so it's compiling it and the way
it stores data is gonna be optimized for
the queries you're gonna be running an
example like a concrete example in arc
in our world is we have an event called
an auction with an auction ID we have a
click later on with also an event
auction ID and we really just want to
join them by auction ID in order to kind
of determine who did this auction have a
click yes or no so the way volte be
worth is you would tell ahead of time
fundamentally hey we're gonna be joining
on auction ID when it loads the data it
makes sure a chart it basically says all
the auction IDs ending like or the same
auction ID depending no matter what the
event type will end up being on the same
partition and then when you run the
actual queries it does the queries add a
partition level so it runs it doesn't
have to shuffle data between partitions
I have a shovel data between nodes it
really does everything kind of in these
like vertical buckets it and that's how
you how we were getting like that
high-speed performance there Oh once
again like why do we do this we really
just wanted to need maybe to bit of a
strong word but we wanted faster data
cuz waiting three hours just took very
long time especially when we did deploys
we want to see how things work or debug
newer campaigns or like every time we
launch the new publisher we really want
to get faster information yeah and we
did a little proof concept and I'm
working well so we stuck with it what
chance do we run into we get another
technology as we go down the road of big
data and a whole other thing we spent a
lot of time trying to go through like
versioning like upgrading versions we
updated versions from Kafka like point A
to point ten before we did this but then
volte B he didn't have the appropriate
connectors druid didn't have the
appropriate connectors there are some
Salty's in the like release notes which
is performance is gonna suck when you
upgrade and sure enough it sucked but we
only found out in production because our
stand environment didn't have the data
volumes so let me start short like this
is caused more trouble than was worth
you know
yeah it's separately what do we do here
just 20 production systems
like you do all these tests on sand and
you're like dummy datasets you need the
Plex production and things are very
different so alters problems and lastly
blamed architecture very elegant just
this idea of having batch in real time
and combining them it's pretty awesome
so then this is the current version so I
call it less is more
I know I don't have a ton of time here
but what really did is we replaced
voltage EB because it was expensive it
was yet another language we realized we
didn't really need the full like
sub-second min and delay with spark
mini-batches we tried streaming we ran
some problems and we decided that spark
batching was okay at least running every
10 minutes instead of every like waiting
three hours so and then everything else
really stayed the same
so scaling issues with volt EB we had to
move back move back I'll talk a little
bit about later but it's hard to them at
scale what I think about paying almost
always you could if you want performance
you can get performance just have to pay
a lot more so when you're saying oh we
couldn't do this we ran to scale issues
you're more and more likely not your
answers like money issues you just
didn't want to pay for it yes so part of
his we ended up we did end up reducing
time sort of like having results within
a minute we suddenly had to wait like 30
minutes
lastly we did spend a ton of time using
all one thing dimensions we finally
introduced air flow like a real
scheduling system instead of rosanna we
resort our own like home build system
and yeah and then other thing we
realized as we've gotten bigger is just
all things to all people it's not a
scalable strategy you give a user data
and they suddenly basically say hey I
deserve this data for the rest of my
life which makes it very hard for you as
like data engineer data engineering team
to sort of rip data away from them so
and that's sort of the challenge we have
now we're trying to remove data we're
trying to kind of actually optimize for
performance and we just can't because so
many people are hooked on the data
running out of time this is very quick
slide just to give some perspective this
was five versions over I would say like
five years each one roughly maybe a year
and a half last said this is
simplification because there's a ton of
overlap between one for another even now
we still have some aggregate data in
redshift because it just hasn't been a
priority to move it away
and then three key lessons learned one
the this is a squirrel eating giant nut
the ideas don't bite off more than you
can chew and the lesson here is if there
is a ton of tech just by being at this
conference well you realize that there's
snowflake there's DBC from Greece
conversation they're like Kafka sparks
dreaming like Kafka streaming and as
much as you as an engineer want to try
every single one you really have to keep
in mind that as your team when you
ideally want to grow your team at the
same time you grow the complexity of
your stack like one engineer cannot
manage a druid cluster a Kafka cluster
like a vole cluster it just doesn't make
any sense so you really have to think
about the technology you use along with
the resources and the people you have
part of is using open-source is great
using vendors is great like they offload
some of it like volt TV helped us do
some of the work using like snowflake
they all do some of that war too but
that's the price you're paying and
that's something to keep in mind this
I'm not gonna play these videos or I
don't I guess I don't have permission
anyway this was me not publicly sharing
them but this was me recording the
documentation swim through the dock
station for Kafka and then the other one
smells the documentation for druid and
it's a 30-second clip each and it's
basically insane like how much you
couldn't figure in Kafka and you get up
and running everything works great you
get a high enough volume and then you
realize holy crap all the configurations
we did three years ago no longer make
any sense and no one has the knowledge
to do it and we've run into this again
and again and again we're just doing the
DevOps and like the configuration for
like big data system is just external
extraordinarily difficult and part of it
is because someone on the dev ops team
may not have familiarity with druid
someone on the data team may not have
from the area to it and it's this sort
of like no-man's land of being like how
do we optimize and how do we tweaked and
tuned our systems and then lastly yeah I
mention I hinted at it earlier but
unless you're the size of Facebook or
Google at like a real huge company like
in our case we really weren't limited by
technology we were really limited by our
like money like we just can't afford to
do all the systems we want and that's
why we have to come up with these like I
would say like simplifications and I
suspect the companies that are like
similar-sized like your challenge is
gonna be technology it's gonna be like
making
cost-efficient and that's it so thank
you the design choice in choosing spark
as your batch processing execution
engine as opposed to something like
redshift spectrum have you looked into
that and so yeah no it's a great
question well the simple answer is when
we move to spark wretches spectrum
didn't exist so like that's very simple
I in turn like at some level we've
committed to spark already I still think
it was the right choice because our data
science team is also using spark right
now so sort of nice that there's this
shared like experience and sharing
knowledge of the spark system that both
teams could benefit from it does also 40
couples you from Amazon somewhat like we
do use Athena for example in some cases
like for some of the queries where we
want to create our lodge directly
without really investing in the true
data pipeline we will we will like after
we upload the data to s3 from using say
core we have another job in airflow that
will index it and load it to Athena and
then when we you and then for Athena we
really just have like a few simple jobs
if you simply like queries to go off of
that instead of having to go through
like a whole separate spark system so I
think it's really interesting your use
case and we like awesome we haven't
explored too much because we were
already in sparkling
[Music]